tränen bei finnlands party
ministerpräsidentin das hat mich heute
früh bewegt seiner marien ein
emotionaler auftritt wirklich berühren
nachdem sie weltweit bekannt geworden
ist durch partie videos jetzt also dass
ich stellt sich all dieser kritik und
all dem druck
ihre stimme zittert überschlägt sich
mehrfach die augen glasig den tränen
nahe ihr ganzer körper angespannt sanna
marin 36 finnlands ministerpräsident in
die jüngste regierungschef in der eu sie
entschuldigt sich spaß gehabt zu haben
neben all der arbeit die freude zu
suchen
ich bin ein mensch und ich vermisse auch
manchmal freude licht und spaß inmitten
dieser dunklen wolken vor einigen wochen
noch wird sie gefeiert für dieses foto
annamaria auf einem rockfestival eine
seriöse politikerin in hotpants sie
machte nie einen hehl daraus dass sie
ein privatleben hat sie ist modern und
nahbar immer seriös dann die wende
letzte woche geht ein video um die welt
sie selbst hätte es wohl nicht auf
instagram veröffentlicht sie tanzt wird
ausgelassen um sie herum freundinnen
bekannte sie schüttelt ihre haare
flirtet mit der kamera dann ein weiteres
video sie und ein sänger hüfte wackelnd
in einem club
die spekulationen auch um drogenkonsum
sie bleibt vorerst ruhig zeigt sich
unbeeindruckt gerät jedoch zunehmend
unter druck die öffentlichkeit
diskutiert verteidigt sie aber andere
frauen springen der premierministerin
zur seite filmen sich ebenfalls tanzend
die kritik wird lauter es geht um
verletzte amtspflichten gefährdung der
nationalen sicherheit um das gegenteil
zu beweisen wird marin vorgeführt wie
ein kind sie entschuldigt sich der
geforderte drogentest negativ dann der
bisherige höhepunkt ein weiteres foto
zwei frauen küssend nackte brüste das
foto entsteht in ihrem amtssitz sie
entschuldigt sich erneut mit brüchiger
stimme und den tränen nah hannah marie
36 finnlands ministerpräsident in die
jüngste regierungschef in der eu frei
und fröhlich noch vor zwei wochen jetzt
sieht sie so aus
[Musik]